god help me to have a new experience
with this today and sometimes I just
need to have a new experience today's
episode is brought to you by grey block
pizza grey block it's that pizza that
you need and that you can enjoy it's at
1811 Pico Boulevard on the way to the
beach in Los Angeles grey block pizza
get that hitter I'd like to announce
some upcoming tour dates I will be in
the Omaha Nebraska at the Omaha
funnybone January 11th and 12th I will
be in Irvine California
January 18th and 19th and January 20th
at the Irvine improv and I will be at
the Columbus funnybone February 8th and
9th in Columbus Ohio and February 22nd
and 23rd at the Houston improv all of
those tickets are on sale now Theo von
comm / tour thank you guys for being
here with me today I hope you had a
wonderful Thanksgiving I did I did a
couple of different things but I want to
start this episode off with some music
and this music is by a beautiful young
man and his name is Evan
Bartles
mother may I open my this is a great big
world waiting right outside mother
Mary's my boy we the people have that
joy mother is my head go I didn't I
tried my mother may have slipped away oh
I didn't I damn right
you can come hmm
pretty powerful stuff there right there
and that's Evan Bartels
and that song is the devil God and me
and man I can you know when he's asking
his mother for permission you know I
could really uh I could relate with that
you know I can you know it's you know as
young men we all need we need permission
from our mothers to to be okay
you know we need permission from our
mothers to feel okay we need permission
you know I needed permission I don't say
we but I needed permission you know from
my mother too
to experience the world comfortably and
and that is pretty fascinating to be
reminded of that and actually to be not
even reminded of that but to be reminded
of that for the first time how much of a
gateway to the world and how I
experience the world and how a young man
experiences the world that our mothers
can be and that's Evan Bartles the devil
God and me thank you guys for being here
that one shook me up out of the gate you
know it's funny how music has that power
huh I wonder if one day they'll find out
that inside of us there are all you know
that inside of us there are like musical
you know I wonder if our maybe our rib
cages have like notes or something built
into them like you know asdf G BAC or
whatever you know each rib is a
different if you hit it with a little
tongue you might get it different out of
our rib cages you know like if we have
music built into us that we don't even
know like it's in and that's why we
connect sometimes with music so much I
wonder you know I wonder what the future
holds what like levels of connectivity
we will find if there's like a whole
other plateau of how we connect you know
with music or with the world if if or
you know with with the atmosphere with
sunlight with water I wonder if we'll be
able to find you know obviously they
make us feel good and they make us think
those things but I wonder if they'll be
able to sign typically you know really
evaluate how start to be able to
quantify how we connect with those
things and we'll really start to be able
to you know almost play the music
that is inside of us better because
we'll be able to orchestrate it from
outside of us like I wonder if there
could be a musical series of tones of
notes that can cure cancer what if they
found that one day what if you just
listen to Jessie's Girl 200 times and
suddenly everything is benign and I
think benign is a good one I'm not sure
if benign is the good one or not but
that was Evan Bartles the devil God and
me and if you want to feel something and
you want to have music pull something
out of you then that's a great song to
do it and we'll have that linked up at
the top of our page on the YouTube thank
you guys for being here with me today
it is late November and it's a time of
discovery I always found this time here
to be a real time of discovery and I
hope you had a great Thanksgiving and I
hope it reminded you of good things and
bad things and just everything I love
this time of year it makes me slow down
and it makes me start to you know just
have some gratitude today I just really
thought about gratitude I was reminded
of it by some of the calls that came in
onto the hotline and we'll get to some
of those and as always the hotline
number is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three I had a good
Thanksgiving I went to Thanksgiving at
Brendan shiebz and Brendan Schaub is a
man he does a podcast he is a you know
he was a wrestler or fighter sorry
and he professional fighter and he does
a podcast called the fighter and the
kids and it's basically I think like a
foster agency sort of an he I don't know
if his he adopted you know it's like his
make-a-wish kid is actually more of a
senior citizen and the man's name is
Brian Collins
and they are teammates and they're
buddies
Brendan's shelves have me over at his
place for Thanksgiving and it was
awesome and he has a beautiful little
son and a beautiful little family and it
was just nice to see it's nice to you
know it's nice to be able to experience
somebody in a different element of their
life because it gets to give you more of
a fuller picture of them of those of
that person like when you see the post
office man
sometime you see your mailman you see
him maybe smoking a joint over by the
bowling lanes and you're like damn mr.
[ __ ] you know mr. Randol he likes to
you know get blown out of his mind and
it starts to it give you a better
picture so now when your Mail's late
you're not just like aw [ __ ] mr. Randol
you're like dang [ __ ] mr. Randol
probably somewhere give him blown out of
his mind or cop in a couple grams and
that's why you know I'm not getting my
amazon paper towel rolls that I ordered
so we just you know it's interesting
when you see somebody in a different
like whenever you see the bus driver at
the supermarket when I was young we had
a bus driver and this lady named dot
wall and a lot of people aren't named
dot I mean that's an easy name it's
basically it's Todd spelled backwards
and then you take one of the DS off do T
and and dot wall had a nice lipstick and
the rest of her kind of looked she
always looked like a senior citizen she
had kind of a gray kind of tone but
beautiful lipstick and she smiled man
eyes she smiled so big when I would see
her in the morning on the school bus she
would get I mean the lipstick would get
on her earlobes that's how big she would
smile and she would open that door and
you know I saw her one time I saw her at
the supermarket and and I saw the things
that were in her car in her shopping
cart
because look I've I've never been a
mystic you know I've never been a you
know a John Edwards crossing over or uh
you know um sorcerer or done anything
where you can look at somebody and guess
their life but if you see somebody
shopping cart at the at the shopping
mall or at the produce store the
supermarket you can really predict
somebody's life a little bit if they got
a couple you know two cans of sardines
and a pumpkin pie you know it might be a
brother you know if they got four jars
of Olives and a bunch of toilet paper
cuz they're gonna be talking [ __ ] you
know it might be a Italian so you know
you can kind of predict people based on
their shopping carts well I remember
seeing dot wall one time the bus driver
dot wall and she was at the she was at
the supermarket and in her cart she just
had you know a Kleenex she had a small
milk and right there I knew you know
that she was you know she was alone she
had a couple Lunchables and um what else
does she have she had a couple
Lunchables and and some toothpaste and I
just knew I from her cart immediately I
knew that she lived by herself you know
and it just felt kind of sad you know it
felt sad a little bit too to see that it
felt kind of lonesome you know and in
that moment I realized why she's smile
while she was so excited on the bus
every day was because that was a little
bit of her family you know and it gave
me a different perception when I saw dot
wall open that bus up in the morning and
and I would sit on that school bus and
most of my life when I was young was on
the school bus because it was fun you
know
there was other children on there and it
was scary sometimes but
but they had the music playing and I
would get fully erect to the music I
would get just damn I mean like my like
my wiener had a dang cocker spaniel in
it and it had heard something real far
away you know my dick was out I mean my
dick was I really out and about on the
front porch if you know what I'm saying
but I love this time of year I loved
going to school right after Thanksgiving
because everybody
it was exciting Christmas what are you
getting what are you getting a hatchet
what are you getting oh my dad got us
you know matching neck braces we're
gonna do a class-action suit you're like
heck yeah congratulations
what are you getting somebody like I'm
getting arm you know why I'm getting all
y'all a flamethrower like man [ __ ] you
man you're lying somebody always lying
I'm getting a tank you know I'm getting
um you know I'm getting uh a pair of
cement pants you like [ __ ] you but some
people were telling the truth and I
remind just remember the excitement that
Christmas was coming I mean if you put
your ear up to the universe you could
hear Santa sleigh so far away and man I
just I loved it and I remember this was
the time of year actually the first time
in my life ever got erection and when I
got did you remember when you got
erection it was baffling and I've talked
about this before but the first time I
remember that I got erection my I
thought it was on you know I thought it
was you know poops that were in my body
trying to come out the wrong way because
it made sense you know because it's the
same shape kind of it you know and I'm
and I was just so scared and I remember
just squeeze and you know
and down with my hands on my wiener cuz
I had that you know I had that two-hand
wiener
and I remember doubling just squeezing
it back into my body I call and I was so
scared you know I was just so alarmed
and I didn't have that that familial
relationship where I could talk to one
of my family members about it so I was
constantly in my house just you know
school
what squeezing what I thought was you
know body you know number two's back
into my body and oh man it was just it
was so scary because then I started
thinking well maybe when I'm doing you
know excrements that I'm not doing a
full you know I'm not doing enough I'm
not doing enough body work to get
everything out the back and that's why
you know I got natural poops kind of do
out the front of my you know through my
body through my wiener and it was just a
lie mean can you imagine the fear of
that looking back on it and how much
anxiety that would put in your body and
I didn't and then I thought I was like
allergic to women because every time I'd
see a couple ladies go by a couple
little duties would try to come out the
front you know and I'm have enough you
know to hand myself back in it was just
so anyway so this time of year has like
you know it's exciting but at the same
time it brings up a little bit of fear
because I had some wild experiences as a
child and that's okay but it's you know
it is what it is and and and what I
loved about this time of year was it
just seemed like a in the wintertime for
some reason I always felt like or in in
Louisiana November this it wasn't too
cold so it wasn't like frigid or you
know freezing so it was just it was
crisp and he felt alert and you could
hear the leading of things were you
could hear the leaves and maybe you know
somebody would hit a call hit hit a
power line hit a power pole with their
car because people would be out drinking
late so you'd see a lot of power lines
in the street bouncing around
electricity you know and you would just
get excited there was
loose electricity in the air literally
and you would get excited and you'd feel
the wind on your face and a new year was
looming right and the first there was
Christmas coming you know baby people
was popping off for baby Jesus and there
was gifts in the air and you could smell
I mean you could smell all the way you
know if the breeze was coming down from
Pennsylvania you could smell them making
her she's up there all the way up there
in Hershey PA you could pitch her a
couple little you know patter sona's
pagano's you know chiseling out a couple
of you know beautiful chocolates that
was gonna come down the river and land
into your stocking at the house and you
could picture and then right after that
you had New Year's and it New Year's was
more for adults I mean kids we didn't do
anything unless there was like wrestling
going on but we were excited because
there was gonna be a new year it was
gonna be at school instead of writing
you know you know 2002 on your paper
you're gonna write 2003 and now was
exciting and it was just an it was a
novel time and it was a big time and it
was it and that's this that's this right
now and we can make it that if we want
to you know it just seemed like a time
of year where things seemed a little bit
fresh where there was enough going on on
the calendar and in people's hearts
where you kind of you started to forget
about the things that had you know if
anybody had wronged you or if you had
wronged yourself over the year I started
to forget about all it had but I went
over to Brendan child's and they had and
they had a nice time and they had you
know Brenda shelves as participants
seventy percent Hispanic or Peruvian I
think or something I mean look at him
the dudes who knows you know he's got
all kind of [ __ ] in it and he had they
had turkey you know pollo
they had you know corn you know corn
salad and they had also
uh some pies couple pies somebody broke
a glass in the ice tray so you had glass
and ice so if you wanted to get a drink
and make it cold you taking a risk right
there you might [ __ ] two sips of dr.
pepper a [ __ ] could kill you if you get
one of those really sharp cubes that
ain't even nice boy that's not cold
water
that's [ __ ] glass papa you know this
is violencia baby no we had a nice time
and it was nice him to invite me and him
just made me feel welcome and and that's
added something that can happen this
time you you can you can invite others
in it's not a walk like you know if may
third you invite somebody over to your
house for a snack
they're looking at you like you might be
um you know a BTK killer or a or a
dangerous human or somebody that makes
soap at their house or a real [ __ ]
creep but this time you you invite
people over it's more normal it's more
natural and so there's just something
very welcoming about this time of year
and so you know I felt welcomed over at
his place and then I went to my
neighbors and had some food over there
and they have a newborn baby over there
and so that was you know just nice to
see and smell a baby man I don't know if
you've ever smelled a baby's neck but
yeah yeah you could smell the Lord some
of the Lord's polishes still on a baby
and you smell it it smells like fresh
and it smells like uh like damn somebody
just all night just been rubbing down
you dryer sheets on this baby's skin no
no that's insane what's been happening
is that's the Lord and you can feel a
little bit of the Lord's polished right
on a baby's skin and baby man Italy you
know and they're not doing nothing ain't
you know touching titty what they lips
and just being you know that little that
little jungle bunny and they that's how
you know that's how God wants them out
there I mean there's a reason why God
puts a baby out into the world and
doesn't start us at 50 years old
imagine you go over to your friend's
house and they got a newborn and he's
[ __ ] 50 and he's sitting there and
he's doing you know smoking Winston's or
maybe he's having a couple you know
sardines or you know them Vienna wieners
and [ __ ] that you're not gonna tell
you're not gonna spend you're not gonna
babysit that dude you're not gonna smell
his neck or tickle him
you [ __ ] tickle him dude who knows
what will happen you might get HPV or
something off his ribcage you don't know
and so that's why God it purposely makes
babies new do you think that what do you
think about that do you think there's a
reason oh my god it starts babies at
zero that's the only thing I can imagine
is that when they're so new we don't
have any judgments against them because
I see a 50 year old dude with a mustache
and it's kind of tinted a little bit
yellow because he's been doing Winston's
like my grandfather used to have his
whole face was yellow because he smoked
about 30 40 Winston's a day and he
polish off him super Winston's they had
it was like four Winston's and one and
he just and he used to blow cigarette
smoke in my eyes and cheat a table rummy
we used to play gin rummy and that was
our family fun but but his whole face
and neck turned green and then they cut
his toes off because he smoked they had
had too much smoke logged in him he had
whatever maybe diabetes or you know
whatever happens but but happy
Thanksgiving man and I hope that this is
a time of year for you that's fresh and
new and I'm trying to take some of that
into my life and make that for myself we
have a we have a neat episode a couple
of calls came in as always the hotline
is nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three again I will be coming
up at these new cities Omaha Nebraska
Irvine California and Columbus Ohio and
Houston Texas in January and February
those tickets are on sale now as well
New Orleans Louisiana and that is
December 20
six the day after Christmas at House of
Blues and those are almost sold out I
think and that's what's going on man
this week I am I'm gonna be hitting the
road and these people called in about it
so let's check in with a call right here
here we go we can request or it's urgent
but you know happy to give him you know
we are here to talk about you because
I'm coming to see you and do you see
with my sister here in the next week and
I got my mom here we just listed to
darnell wrong podcast and all she has to
say is Gang Gang we got her we got them
hitters broke Gang Gang ladies bro love
you too man I'm glad you bring your mom
out and I'm glad you're bringing your
sister out and that's nice you know
there's some people that comes out and
sometime his family and you can see them
laugh together and there's something
special in watching that for me and and
and I want to thank everybody on
Instagram we did the relative rodeo last
week and relative rodeo I didn't give
enough rules with it relative rodeo is
where you find somebody at your family
or a friend of the family at a holiday
gathering and you got a hug you hug them
you don't jump on their back
this isn't mating this isn't you know
touching each other's [ __ ] a little
sweaty though you know you know sweaty
glans and everything and being glandular
this is the opportunity for you to hug
somebody
and go beyond where people would usually
separate because if you hug somebody
usually people separate a second and a
half but this you ride through that
uncomfort and you stay with that person
and at first you notice a lot of people
try to get out of it or whatever but
then eventually they fall into the love
and that was relative rodeo it was fine
somebody at your holiday gathering that
doesn't expect it and you drop that hug
on and you just try to hold onto them
for as long as you can and you don't
have to get to eight seconds the goal
was eight seconds and people submitted a
lot of videos you can
vonda's on instagram hashtag relative
rodeo and a lot of people also
misspelled rodeo but um but I want to
say we had a call that came in about one
of those and here we go
hey Co success Thank You Toki hey man I
tried to look at eight-second rodeo with
the mother of my child
we've been trying to co-parent and then
we try to get back together and dinner
she's over Thanksgiving with my family
beautiful Thanksgiving everything's
great wonderful she was there busting my
balls you know flirting she kind of
pinched my nipple Oh beautiful and
pinching somebody's nipple that's that
means a lot sometimes because that means
somebody's willing to touch you know an
important part of your body that's first
base it used to be now first base I
think is really smelling somebody's name
you know the times have changed
first base now is stealing a
[ __ ] cellphone or something but
back in the day first base used to be
chest you know titty or they used to
call it titty I don't think they even
call it that anymore but so she checked
your nipples and that's nice sometimes
you know in some cultures that's
everything you know in China or Japan if
you you know you you know do some body
gas or you you know touch somebody's
nipple or something y'all are [ __ ]
y'all might as well open up a small
business you know or start an LLC
together but okay so this is in Kentucky
and you wanted to try the relative rodeo
and you showed up and you guys have had
some differences but you guys seem to be
getting along at the Thanksgiving onward
you know just remind me that you know I
still got a little bit of man boobs left
hp-310 187 pinched my nipple farted with
me and I played on things feel good this
is doing a good place um I guess I need
to tell the backstory [ __ ] eto put on me
a while back I had to get clean cups
drugs
we go back chanting amended so we can be
around each other we could talk and work
out kids okay so you guys got family she
had it's restraining order you had to
get clean and be able to be around the
children so you're bringing a lot to the
table
this [ __ ] y'all aren't y'all are
starting at the zero yard line here at
Thanksgiving y'all are starting in damn
over time let's hear more something
trying my hardest me great good for you
brother
that's awesome here that you trying hard
man you sound good homeward like back to
the story ago Thanksgiving having the
meal I try to put a hug on a man um and
you know she said a great hug rape what
is that
that's the worst saying I've ever heard
man hug rape god what is next man let's
hear more men on me interrupt you but
I've never heard that term and that
really I mean that makes me upset you
know that makes me feel like my insides
just want to you know you just all get
together and [ __ ] just eat a bunch of
cement and not even do anything anymore
homeward she took the key and put it in
her hand you know and was you know
either thing you know like I knew like
I'm like a knife sticking out of her
knuckle with the key like I said how
great you can't do that so you know
luckily mom my brother Mark cut off the
video we say they'd say that okay I mean
I kind of wish I don't beat him but I
don't know she just keeps me cool one
day what disappear story man this is
real it happen and there you go man some
of the relative rodeos you know that
seems like one that didn't go well you
know especially if she put that little
key between her fingers like that
you know she that she's making a little
spicy hitter
that's that [ __ ] prison popper you
know that's you know you're talking to
somebody in prison you're talking about
when you guys are gonna get out maybe
you're gonna open up a coffee shop
together or something
they look over in a distance you hit him
that prison popper with that little car
key between your fingers and that is
dangerous brother and so obviously you
know
yeah maybe don't try to hug her and if
you do just do one or two seconds
you know relative rodeo sometimes isn't
for everybody but I appreciate you you
know giving it a shot and
congratulations on staying clean dude
because a lot of rodeo riders are clean
I mean you can't do a bunch of coke and
get on the back of a big goat or
anything you know unless you're thinking
about doing something nasty but you
can't get on one and think about doing
you know achieving a goal or being a you
know an actual rodeo person so this is
beautiful man I appreciate you calling I
appreciate you trying it out um we had
another couple calls that came in listen
listen let's hit one or two more turn
think of what else happened during my
Thanksgiving um
what's been going on you know I started
looking at some magazines for Christmas
shopping the other day and AM and this
should just exhausting you know I'm
noticing that since I get at since we
get advertised to all year now it's like
constant advertising everywhere now
looking for Christmas stuff to me feels
just exhausting you know how does that
feel for you I wonder I mean you just
like [ __ ] it just used to seem like you
bought something at a certain time you
know when there was a time when if you
you know we got shoes at the beginning
of school that's when we got everything
if he was a child that's when you got
everything and you got toys at Christmas
time and you got one more toy or two
more toy at your birthday and then that
was it you got candy at Halloween you
got candy at Christmas you got candy at
Easter you got candy at people's
birthday parties you asked for candy at
the supermarket and your mom would beat
that ass point or beat that neck dude
when I was a kid look no kid really
likes to get that ass pop-pop do you
know but the worst part for me was
getting my neck hit
do my neck it feels like just it's so
sensitive I have very sensitive neck I
mean you can't even barely wear a scarf
because I can't be really really handle
it
and your neck my neck is like a
sensitive is like sixty or seventy
little bitty nutsacks all-in-one I mean
it's a thing it's gentle boy if somebody
even whistles my neck [ __ ] hurts a
little like my [ __ ] is sensitive and and
back in a day man and my mom sometimes
if she wanted to get you she would hit
you on that ass and I got a B I got a
hearty ass dude I got the acid but you
know kind of like a black girl with Down
syndrome you know I got that D s booty
and a man though if she hit my neck bruh
oh you'd uh butter finger came out one
time with a real was it a butterfingers
no it was Charleston chew and they used
to have a family called the UH they used
to have a candy called Charleston chews
and I don't know what it was I don't
know who Charleston was or anything or
if it might have been the city was named
from but and my mother said i'ma grab it
it was in a yellow wrapper if you were
bad and in the supermarket and you
wouldn't even see she would grab one
sometimes on the way in and if we were
bad because we would be bad when we hit
the flour I we crack open a sack of
flour and you know by the time we hit
all four we look like a couple of
[ __ ] coke heads you know we've been
drinking olive oil
you know we're [ __ ] up everybody gots
a pocket a stolen you know um semi-sweet
little chocolates more chocolate morsels
you know we [ __ ] up and my mom man
she breaking when you weren't looking
she break out that choice and chew and
hit you in the neck with that [ __ ] now
do you can feel your whole life flash
before your eyes you get hit by that
[ __ ] you be like what the [ __ ] man
I end up working at the bank you know
you get hit you be like what the [ __ ]
I'm gonna have two kids man one of
them's going to jail one of them's gonna
be a lot thinking long like damn I mean
you my mother would beat the [ __ ]
future into you with that Charleston
chew let's take another call the hotline
is always nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three I want to let you
guys know next week I'm gonna talk about
I've talked I've thought about you know
bringing it up but I'm gonna talk about
sobriety some next week it's just so you
guys know why I'm into that universe and
how I ended up you know wanting to be
involved in that I'm hoping to anyway if
I feel compelled you know something
talking about some of that stuff is you
know it's kind of personal sometimes and
I just want to be in the right like mind
and heart frame to be able to talk about
it
Oh hate to interrupt you guys but I got
to tell you that my skill set is lacking
I don't have a lot of skills
well skills share is an online learning
platform with over 20,000 classes in
business design and technology and more
you can take classes in social media
marketing data science mobile
photography creative writing you name it
they've got it you know a lot of times I
think to myself like man I would love to
be an accountant but I don't want to go
to four years of accounting school or
you know bookkeeping well you can go to
Skillshare and whatever your oh I want
to be this you can take a couple of
classes on there to at least have the
skill set to be able to do it then you
can go practice it in the real world I
mean I'm not saying that it's a it's a
get out of college free card or anything
but it's definitely a way to get a skill
and get active right now that some of
the top ten classes that this past
weekend listeners have signed up for
it's Skillshare our Facebook ads for
e-commerce presentation essentials how
to share ideas that inspire action how
to make Android apps and music producer
masterclass so those are a few of them
whether you're trying to deepen your
professional skill set or just
decide hustle go to Skillshare dot-com
that's right and Skillshare is offering
this past weekend listeners two months
of unlimited access for over 20,000
classes just $0.99 go to Skillshare
dot-com / Theo again go to Skillshare
dot-com / Theo to start your two months
for $0.99 right now that Skillshare comm
/ Theo let's take a call onward hey Theo
this is pagan from a little town in
south Louisiana dedicated listening to
this past weekend pagan thank you for
calling pagan that's a wild name brother
if that is I could have I could have
misheard you and if I did I'm sorry but
pagan is uh that's the dark arts man we
may be talking to uh you know
Lucifer's a little cousin right here on
word brother stupid ruin the whole
weekend
man I'm sorry to hear that dude let's
hear about it though
I mean he'll you know I'm I'm empathetic
or sympathetic but at the same time I
really want to know what happened let's
go did it give it a day drinking and
then and the disappointment from with
that and not tear apartment cap drinking
and uh late night I go get Domino's you
know had that girl craving you know them
beer munchies and well I've heard a weed
munchies I never heard of beer munchies
but I mean I guess that drunk craving
man you know I used to you know what I
used to do when I would get a little bit
of cocaine you know in the first time
ever got cocaine I was in college and
somebody said the guy that sold it to me
I think was a idiot
and he said it was performance-enhancing
drug so I'm doing you know a half a gram
or whatever and then I [ __ ] go for a
run so I'm there in Baton Rouge we
in Iran about nine and a half miles you
know I was about to [ __ ] play for
Jerry DiNardo I'm out there you know I'm
not there pushing sleds with t-bob a
bear you know I'm getting it done and
and so I had a total wrong idea of drugs
and but when I would get you know i when
i would get on to like a gas station
when I was running I realized when I was
at a gas station
I had a thirst for soup for Campbell's
canned soup and I've never had that
before
you know I've always been a natural you
know a natural sipper somebody who sips
you know I sip regular things that
people should be sipping like if you're
at a you know a park I'll drink you know
water or if you're at home I have a you
know a a kool aid or a little um you
know uh juice or something so we usually
if I'm at a gas station a service
station I get Gatorade or Powerade but
on when I realize when I was doing
cocaine if I hit a [ __ ] gas station
dude I wanted broth I wanted that broth
so I'm running all around LSU Louisiana
State University campus I'm in college
I'm running high as hell and I'm [ __ ]
just polishing off cans of raw you know
Campbell's chicken noodle like it's
[ __ ] Gatorade Brian I was powered up
I was Hardy as hell brought
performance-enhancing that's cocaine
baby and so I don't know what I was
talking about day drinking let's hear
what you said again sorry
only Domino's no drunk raving you know
them beer marches and oh I was saying
yeah sometimes you can get you know a
desire for something else whenever
you're on a certain drug you know like
if you're on nah like I don't do cocaine
anymore and I also probably won't you
know take a nibble off of a strange gals
behold anymore
you know I'm saying it's like because
those things go hand in hand I mean one
of them is a gateway drug to the other
you know you so anyway this is getting a
little bit wild let's go homeward from
my way home there's two cattle in the
middle of a dark hallway and smoke this
cow invest my car real bad and there's a
band that hit one as well as two cars
that you hit these cows and the cops
come they could smell I've been drinking
in the you know field sobriety it locked
me up and do a breathalyzer on me at
that Asian enough to charge the DWI
girlfriend disappointed means you like
me and family disappointed just really
want some inspiration words about
sobriety and how you guys realize it
told me that I could relate to people
out there other than myself so lobbies
do appreciate a man I didn't mean to cut
you off but you know I appreciate it you
know we got your message there and you
know I'm sorry to hear it
but if you kill an animals dude because
you out there drinking huh you know what
happens next you have a six pack and you
[ __ ] you know you hatch it up a
couple of damn aardvarks or something
you know what happens next you have a
you know a fifth alene or something or a
couple cup cups of lean or whatever and
you you know you throw in Death Star's
at a dam you know pack of flamingos or
something in the park what's next you
know when does it stop because I heard
you say you know your family's
disappointed and your girlfriend's
disappointed but it also sounds men and
this might be judgement for me but it
sound like you you know you're like
you're disappointed some in your in your
actions because if you killing animals
I mean what's there not only thing to
kill out there that is people brah you
know you're lucky you could have had a
couple of humans
you know if fat humans or something so
that's pretty much maybe a blessing a
hidden blessing that you hit cows
because cows let's be honest bro they
don't give a [ __ ] if they die look at a
cow in the eyes dude first of all it's
got eyes on different side it's not even
a cow isn't even using all of its
abilities man accounting doing nothing a
cow is an old-fashioned refrigerator bro
they're standing out there they got milk
they got you know if you hold that outer
outer to the side of them and let the
Sun hit it you can make it you could
spray cheese out of that pack but they
got milk and meat in them a cow is the
original Frigidaire that's the truth
right there but I'm sorry to hear that
man and what suggestions do I have or
words you know nobody can tell you if
you're an alcoholic nobody can tell you
if you have problems with drugs or
alcohol except for you you know I was
doing you know I was running eight or
nine miles keyed up on a grandma cocaine
with no shirt on wearing a pair of
orange Sun Bros jumping in the back of
people's a part you know jumping over
fences and [ __ ] into people's yards and
and drinking canned soup for you know
for hydration and I didn't think I had
an issue everybody's idea of if they
have an issue is different but I do know
this that you sound like somebody that
wants to feel better than you do and
even if you maybe want to tell you know
check out a couple AAA meetings or check
out that kind of environment if you got
a DWI they may offer that as an option
to you through the court system so you
can do that sometimes and still be able
to keep your license so that might be a
good option you know to take that
experience because it has proven to be
an effective option for other people and
no matter what I think it'll be
inspirational to you you may have a
night you may have a problem you may not
you may just need some inspiration you
may need some perspective
and I think you can get those things
there at some of those meetings so maybe
see what the judge has to offer but you
know the fact that you even called in
and you're making things like this
important in your life that's good
you're thinking about this you want to
do better and a lot of people don't and
so I commend you for that but and keep
your head up out there man and damn bruh
cuz what's next dude you know you
[ __ ] throwing you know you hiding a
firecracker and a [ __ ] Falcons throat
what's next so be safe we had a couple
of calls that came in about nut vember
and we're coming up on the end of
November no nut in November where people
don't do masturbation and so let's hit a
couple of those really quick homeward
hey what's up Bo gang gang gang gang
papa
and thank you for calling I appreciate
you guys Josh I'm calling from Florida a
little nuts in more question for you
okay you know I've been doing good you
know I've been trying to resist the dark
arts you know I'm saying but uh I don't
know if I believe that but let's hear
more we're at about three weeks now you
know oh wow three weeks man that's
beautiful congratulations you probably
stackin you're probably feeling your gak
a little bit in your throat you might
clear you might clear your throat and
have things be a little bit thicker
that's coming up in your mouth more no
porn no masturbation Wow good job
homeward but I I met this girl you know
things been it's been going well you
know they're gonna get a little hot and
heavy
you know that's nature man that ain't
you a lot of times we you know I'll get
by a girl and I got her fired up 19
[ __ ] me brah that's nature nature's
been making things [ __ ] forever
so let's don't you know you see a guy
he's like I'll make all the ladies hot
like do you don't do [ __ ] bro mother
nature's out there doing that [ __ ] you
just riding her vine let's go but uh
haven't got to that point where I got
said you know let's finish the deed oh
you got to bust out you mean more but uh
I got this condition you know it's a
month
when I got these kind of like enlarged
veins in my nutsack oh yeah yeah I'm
saying I think it's called as varicocele
oh yeah my friend are not really my
friend but this kid I knew and his mom
had varicose veins in her neck and [ __ ]
and they busted out one winter cuz it
got real cold and they busted and
because you're supposed to like massage
him or something at night if it's gonna
be cold and she [ __ ] you know you
know
r.i.p you know homer and it makes the
blue balls
amplified oh yeah why new another dude
he had a a Horta went straight from his
heart to his nuts
so his nutsack was a brilliant like a
little heart it was like a little you
know a little sidecar for Islam heart so
he really got that you know that that
fifth a order was really is nuts or you
know he had a they had a uh ventricle or
something what does it called a like a
main vein it's called a like the
superhighway a vein when went straight
from the neck to the nuts and they had
that and he had that and so basically
the way his body usually your body has
like six aortas or whatever in your
heart and it holds some and uses some
and a orders our little it's almost like
it's little places where your heart
keeps blood because your heart can't
hold all the blood in one space that's
[ __ ] you know your heart would be
dumb if it did that so your heart has
little spaces so it can manage the blood
better and he he had a vein went
straight from his heart to his scrotum
and that thing went all you know it
would Harbor you know so anyway anyway
let's go sorry so I'm just you know I'm
walking around smells like my balls
weigh like 10 pounds no no no man
because you're um you don't have that
much blood in your heart and like like
I'm being tortured man like it's painful
I are laid over so then see I just said
you know what man [ __ ] it I'm just gonna
do is be myself but you know no dark
arts note
tation you know no point I just want to
wear your thoughts you know is it is it
cool to go that route you know I'm
saying well look I think you can do this
you know they used to have this thing it
was called looking for the lightning and
it was like when we were probably like
15 or whatever everybody would try to
not touch themselves and have wet dreams
and see who you know who could get him
the soonest and and I used to get him
all the time and I had some crazy one
brought a lot of my dreams were in you
know I was in you know different
countries and stuff Central America
Honduras you know I was in Guatemala you
know a lot of my dreams had beautiful
backdrops and so it was easier for me to
come you know to do spray and a lot of
people I think have more localized
dreams you know it's not as easy to bus
down if you just [ __ ] and if you if
in your dream you're at your you know
your uncle's you know oh you know you
know vacuum shop or whatever it's not as
exciting where I'm in [ __ ] Barbados
while I'm resting you know you over here
milling around around a cafeteria or
something so consciously so I'll say
this man I think if you want to write
you know if you want to look for the
lightning man then go do it and that's
just you know holding the line until
nature does its thing but I don't you
know if you've already done three weeks
I would ride it out if you get there
with a young lady I think that that's
different you know I think you know I
didn't really even know all the rules of
no Knut November I just thought you
couldn't masturbate and you couldn't you
know do self spray and stuff like that
so but look man I appreciate you I
applaud you even trying it and I think
that this program is going to evolve
over time and I mean next year you might
have 60 or 70 people you know buddies
you know all getting together in the
morning and not jerking off and just
looking at each other and you know
wishing for the best because I mean
these liberals you know these these
overt liberals they're going to start
outlawing probably ejaculation
soon you know that that that could that
be on the docket and what's next you
know in some men should only be allowed
look I've had enough busts I'm that you
know I'd be happy to say hey no more
over here alright let's take one more
call about the no nut November here on
name's Andy from New Jersey Andy from
Jersey thank you for calling and New
Jersey is uh you know they have a lot of
air pollution up there let's hear more
and just want to check in your progress
on a no-knock November man we're all in
single and it's hard you know and just
wanted to check in and see what kind of
advice you get had you know people like
the men like us gentlemen they're trying
to keep that energy and keep that good
thing yes and uh she's promising this
from this month and hopefully for longer
we can shout out yeah gang in my gang
gang Papa and you know I appreciate you
asking me and inquiring man because I
didn't do too well you know I busted out
this month probably you know five times
and that's pretty sad I think so I kind
of felt I mean I failed myself last
night and I had a stack going inside of
me I mean man I could feel even you know
my skin felt more moisture cuz you know
we don't realize what that she does to
us you know when your cheetah boy your
elbows are sharper you see a dude that
hasn't busted in like a month brah
I mean he could [ __ ] you know he
could lick open the side of a chicken
you know he has those he has real
abilities old-school abilities and yeah
man I uh and I you know I've struggled
with that I struck you know I've been
dealing with a lot on the on my own side
about you know really trying to reframe
how how I look at commitment and
relationships and that sort of thing and
uh and I've been having like some
visceral reactions to that where I
I want to act out or I want to do
something you know you know kind of
Randy and so I've been doing
masturbation some and so you know I feel
bad I wasn't I didn't try to you know I
wasn't you know I didn't like give up on
myself for anything but I you know I
just didn't do that great a few times
but thanks for checking in about it man
I do appreciate that
we got a call here that came in last
week or two weeks ago we had a kid a
young fella that called in and said he
was going through a breakup okay and
here's a response that you guys have for
that uh this young this young fella
right there I think oh this is a oh just
calling uh-oh
yo huh I think that's half my name
that's pretty cool you know that's like
if you know my name was Darius you'd be
like hey this is Rios I'm like Oh Homer
Wow a young man that called in worried
about his breaking up with his
girlfriend was worried about his
girlfriend's gonna break up with him and
I just wanted to say you know like I
think everybody goes through that that
really touched me and I just wanted to
tell him you know like hey you're a
young man and as everybody tells you
that you know things get easier
throughout your life and stuff like that
and you get a lot of more lot more
perspective but nothing ever gets easier
and you know with heartbreak and
relationships and stuff like that it's
tough but you know it took me 20 years I
had to [ __ ] break up and you know
with my high school sweetheart and we
went through a lot of things but you
know I'm married now
and I found the love of my life in it
and I wouldn't have found her if I
hadn't went through everything that I
had went through so I know it's hard to
just keep your head up and
you know whatever so that guy didn't
have a ton of information but his main
message was wasn't bad that in the end
it all works out so it's hard to see
where you are in this moment right and
it's it's it's it's it's interesting cuz
you know older people always tell
younger people you know it's gonna work
out and that's true
it's going to but when you're young you
can't see that you can't really see that
you know and and just hold on man feel
the things you're gonna feel that's what
I would say don't cloud them with other
stuff don't clot em up with drugs and
alcohol and don't cloud them up with you
know running out and diving into some
other local stank you know be natural
don't all of a sudden you know start
doing men or doing you know you know
selling your body or something don't do
anything crazy or selling used cars
don't do anything real crazy be natural
for a little bit let yourself feel some
of the pain and also let yourself like
you know recognize you know maybe what
you could have done different in the
relationship and not in a bad way but in
a way that you'll do it better next time
because if this girl is the love of your
life then I believe that you know God or
whatever a higher power will give you an
opportunity to to have at it again you
know for you guys to experience one
another again and man you can be a
better person then but you'll be okay in
the meantime man and it is gonna hurt
some but you know just know that there's
a lot any man you talk to probably has
experienced that same hurt so you know
just don't feel alone Brother Bear you
got this let's take another call that
came in here man nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three is the hotline
as always you can call us and hit us up
here homeward hey what's happenin Theo
von this is Joelle Garcia at a Yucaipa
California
hey Joelle Garcia de Yucaipa thank you
for calling sir let's hear it and
listening to you recent
Podcast you just put out and you know
excited Monday morning starting off my
week right and gang gang no you made me
laugh or first twenty thirty minutes or
so then you started just getting deep
and your feelings and talking about your
mom and he'd break to you bro but I try
to hear that [ __ ] Monday morning Nelson
tena enlighten my day with your moods
and
and make me laugh and smile and you know
just go through that whole deal so uh
you know everyone's got to talk about
their mom and their feelings and
throughout their days and things like
that but trying to laugh brother so uh
you know I hate to be the bearer of bad
news but you know feel better ma'am
Thank You Man
I appreciate you calling and saying that
yeah I feel you man and sometimes look
out you know I don't know when I start
these episodes how I'm gonna be or
what's gonna go on and I know sometimes
you know I get a little too caught up
and you know just in myself and my own
feelings like basically just stuck you
know stuck kind of worrying about stuff
inside of myself and I don't want to you
know Debbie down you guys as days either
or anything like that um you know I wish
that I'd gotten through a lot of some of
these you know normal ways of feeling
and learning when I was younger you know
some of the issue for me is is that I'm
kind of a late bloomer in a lot of ways
you know I just started really having
feelings like real you know or being
like self-aware about to little over two
years ago and so you know I kind of have
this whole new kind of world going on
and it's still tough for me to learn to
separate you know what is like things
that are just for me and what are things
like that I can talk about I can a
public space you know and I didn't know
when I started this podcast how this was
good you know I didn't know that there
were times I would be talking about you
know stuff you know that other people
didn't talk about or you know I didn't
listen to any podcast before I did this
so you know I didn't have a real strong
idea so I don't know I mean I've
listened to a few episodes here and
there of you know maybe Joe Rogan and
and but I didn't have a you know super
strong idea of how to do one where you
know it's just you and you by yourself
and I didn't know some of the stuff I
was going to talk about and I didn't
know some of the stuff I'd be kind of
going through but I do feel you man and
I am cognizant of that you know I don't
want to be like a Debby you know a you
know a you know a Donald downer so we'll
keep that on tabs and I appreciate you
calling in oh we have this here nick
says opposite let's hear this you know
what's going on man is Aaron from
Northern Ontario just want to thank you
for calling Aaron and a lot of beautiful
Canadians that have called in and thank
you for that man you know it's it's
amazing how loving uh how loving and
just how loving people really are the
great white north
homeward estas say I love the show but
secondly just going back a couple weeks
ago now you had a gentleman call in
who's you getting a little emotional
online and you weren't too sure if you
want to have these serious shows or
these funny shows and I just want to say
man and I probably speak for most of us
listeners shows though you man you're
feeling emotional I want to get
emotional I want to get all up in those
emotions if you're feeling funny bang
hope they got a referee around here this
is a frisky guy on work week I want to
kick back and have a laugh you know I'm
here for the co bond experience and I'm
not here for you know putting on a show
for all these rascals you feel me all
right man keep moving onward get that
hitter gang gang man thanks for the call
yeah you know I appreciate your
sentiment man I appreciate you saying
some of those things you know cuz I mean
there's definitely you know like I feel
like you know sometimes I feel a little
bit like ashamed of myself I guess
because you know I guess in some ways I
didn't really have a place to talk to
except to talk to myself about early
you know I don't know when I first
started this podcast I felt like I was
talking to someone or I felt like I was
just talking to myself you know I don't
know
but you know it's been interesting man
it's been interesting
you know I guess part of me someone
feels a little bit of shame to be like
you know talk about like emotions and
stuff like that you know a lot of them
like I don't really know some of the
feelings that I've been having and stuff
I've been kind of scared especially
recently
you know this year with my like career
has been changing a lot you know and it
feels like a lot of pressure and you
know I've talked about some of that kind
of stuff and it's scary
I'm is scary you know it's scary to feel
like you know people you know all your
life you felt like you've been saying
you can do something and then now people
are looking at you to see if you can do
it and that can you know that's just
been kind of alarming and I've been you
know when I got man I'm [ __ ] just a
late bloomer you know I didn't have a
bullet you know like a system when I was
growing up or somebody told me well this
is how you relate with women this is how
you stand up for yourself this is how
you you know this is you know I don't
know my mother didn't give me a lot of
those you know whatever Evan bartels was
saying in the beginning what was he
saying let me go back to that real quick
let me go back to that real quick so I
can reference that
yeah that's heaven Bartles right there
and so I think some stuff I didn't you
know I just didn't I don't know I did I
mean my you know my dad wasn't around I
didn't I just didn't have a strong
system of what was okay and what wasn't
okay when I was young and after that I
got trapped inside of myself for about
25 years or 20 years or whatever and so
now I'm getting free and so I think some
things I'm learning on the fly and you
know it is kind of a bummer because if I
you know I wear a lot of my stuff on my
sleeves and so it's hard for me to like
come in and just hide and just be funny
you know and it's tough when you don't
have like drugs and alcohol sometimes to
hide behind that not hide behind but you
you know you want to just [ __ ] have
fun you know blow a blunt and talk about
a [ __ ] you know I'm wondering if a
falcon could pick up a [ __ ] more than
two marbles at the same time you know I
want to do all of that [ __ ] but
sometimes my head gets a little clogged
but I appreciate you guys being a part
of this journey you know this thing this
podcast and I think it'll be times when
it gets funnier and I've been trying to
also calm down man it's just been on
this has been this has been the Crazy's
here in my life I think in some ways you
know and I don't even know what to make
of it and I don't know sometimes if I
have all the proper systems built into
me
because I want to you know I want to
best serve you know the opportunities
that you know that that God and life has
put in front of me you know and not just
for myself you know so I don't know
I don't also maybe don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about there you know
let's take one more call man in this
came in from an old favorite hey Theo
this is ojp from down Alabama and holler
did you know wow man I've been listening
to you though really enjoy thanks JP &
JP have a um he has a spare appendage he
has a not taxidermy what's it called he
has a fake of paint here's a you know he
has that prosthetic hitter so if that
dude kicks you in the ass brahim like
[ __ ] it might you know the foot might
be from a Woolworths you know or from
Macy's so he has and he also had a
$20,000 leg that he had at one time he
had a high-end led but I think he got
repossessed or something I can't
remember what our previous conversation
was but that's [ __ ] crazy boy he's
standing in the yard and next thing you
know you know those bounty hunters come
and [ __ ] wheel off with your [ __ ]
calf and [ __ ] they wheel off with all
your tarsals that's Wow brah you like
bring back my shoe that's my show and
they're just like but it's cruising out
but JP from Alabama man I've always
appreciated his calls and thank you man
I've wondered if you still listen
sometimes and I'm happy to know that you
do homeward still one of my favorite
comedians
he'll an entertainer I noticed so man
listen do you see might be struggling a
little bit with some of the success
you've been having over the last year I
just want to let you know man forget to
be too much just hang it up come down
here and work with me you know I'm right
outside of Birmingham and a warehouse
down here you know driving a forklift
and a freeze I guarantee you you'll wish
you had to quit your damn comedian job
you come down you go to work with me my
friend
you'll be so damn tired you won't even
have time be worried about these things
you'd be worrying about your mom on you
you woman's and all laugh turn you man
you got it made out there and Hollyweird
enjoy yourself I love you brother happy
holidays gang gang man Thank You JP dude
I think I actually needed to hear that a
lot you know how to think I needed hear
from a voice that I'll you know like
could relate to a little bit or just
like uh you know you sound a little bit
the same as me some so you know and
that's the thing about life sometimes
you have to you we got to hear from we
have to hear some things from a voice we
need to hear from you know and you you
know one of the truths is man you know
what's funny is when you say that JP it
makes me wonder well what's my part in
like the most recent like what have I
done recently in my life that you know
has given me more time this you know sit
and stir sometimes in my own feelings
and the truth is I haven't been as
active as I could be you know I haven't
been you know trying new experiences and
I haven't been you know embracing life
and I haven't been you know making my
gratitude lists in the morning you know
and I haven't really been taken as much
action as I can to be a part of the you
know to be a a part of the system a part
of the living world you know a part of
things feeling good and having fun and
so I think you know that's one thing
that I can do is just you know like
Brooks was here bro like he said it get
busy living or get busy dying dude and
that's Andy Dufresne bro from [ __ ]
what is it Shark Tank or something I
don't even know what it is the prison
movie busting Saddles but
Thank You Man you're right you know
sometimes it's like you know I do think
yeah we can get back on you know
hopefully on the on some of the funnier
side of things you know and uh and I
appreciate you saying that dude and who
the [ __ ] has you driving a forklift in a
freezer man are you sure you're not
kidnapped bro dude who kidnapped you
this sound like you got like you under
house arrest over at you know over at
Omaha Steaks what's going on I Love You
Man I appreciate you calling in dude I
really appreciate it I appreciate all of
our listeners always for this past
weekend yeah I do it you know I think
one thing I haven't been feeling JP is I
just been feeling more did I just been
feeling more um there's just I've been
feeling more uh too much energy too much
going on you know and so yeah I want to
slow things down in some ways but get
more active in others and I'm part of me
just wants to be not afraid to just you
know I think sometimes when the podcast
started getting busier this year I
started getting you know get it gets in
your head you know I mean it's easier to
shoot free throws and then people come
and stand around and watching you shoot
free throws and you start to I don't
know it's net it's just nature that you
feel nervous maybe or for me it is so
yeah it's just been a unique year but
you know I'm gonna talk that I have a
new experience with the rest of this
year and I'm I hope that you know that
my higher power you know helps me to
just not you know this world is about
all of us and it's not about me and just
to think about you know what can I do to
help others and to be of service
because by helping others I know that
I'm a feel better myself you know and
and I think that the world has exciting
things in store for all of us and all of
our brothers and all of our mothers and
all of our sisters and all of our
all of our cousins and all of our
children I think that they got some gang
gang stuff heading our way I want to
thank you guys for your support
we'll play I'll play having bottles full
on the way out man because it's just
such a beautiful voice in a beautiful
ballad and and you guys be good to
yourselves and you do deserve it and I'm
gonna do it for myself
and I'm gonna try to get these spirits
lifting and get them swifting and just
get action stay action bro dude I'll
tell you this joke that I thought of the
other day I forgot about I might have
told it before but did you hear about
the Fonz
he got AIDS and that's I could joke
about Arthur Fonzarelli he don't know
who the Fonz is he was um anyway
whatever go look it up I'll see you guys
next week and I'll see you in Washington
DC this coming weekend and I'll be
taping the episode from there actually
and I'm heavily looking forward to that
and then I'll see you see you in
Lexington
New Orleans Houston Irvine Omaha and
Columbus all tickets on sale now Theo
von comm / tour onward
mother may I open my this is a great big
world waiting right outside mother
marries my boy we the people have that
true mother may I raise my head go I
didn't I tried my mother may have
slipped away though I did not damn right
oh you can come
you can't comfort me
oh I do have your May
stuck in my ear and down the plane
though I beg you let me be
there will you know my plea the crown
alas I wearing say well I would give to
drag you can go